my name is Zack sheíll I'm the
co-founder and CEO of rhombic sand I
participated in the entrepreneurship and
civil and environmental engineering
program and spring of 2014 my co-founder
and I had been working on it
on rhombic for a couple months but the
program really provided a structured
course that got us all the way to where
we needed to be to go out and begin
fundraising as soon as we graduated and
finish the course the biggest success as
an entrepreneur is is us being here
today at the rhombus office we're in the
middle of ramping from 35 to 50
employees we've raised thirty million
and capital over the course of the last
five years
and yeah the fact that I'm sitting here
today getting this interview is the big
biggest success as an entrepreneur today
really one of the things that brought me
to the program was the professors that
teach it they've got an unbelievable
wealth of experience from venture
capital to being entrepreneurs
themselves
and really haven't gone through every
stage of early-stage startup life so the
program curriculum is basically a crash
course for everything that you need to
know to start a company
it covers initial team make up to
settling on a Minimum Viable Product -
how do you bring that product to market
how do you finance it how do you
continue to scale it so it really is an
A to Z program covering all stages of
the early-stage startups life the
program was invaluable and teaching us
everything that we needed to know to
start a company we graduated in June
2014 and closed our first seed financing
round in August of that year really took
what we learned in the program and we
were able to generate a convertible note
begin fundraising almost immediately
graduating class biggest challenge for
my co-founder myself as non-technical
co-founders was building the software
company we'd never recruited screen
hired or managed software developers and
engineers before so that was a real
learning curve that we had to go up and
the course provided us with a network of
people that we were able
leaned on throughout that process to
provide a support mentorship and advice
the program instructors expertise was
invaluable really leverage ray Leavitt
to think about or go to market and a
Minimum Viable Product within the
construction industry talk to folks like
Pedro and Mike about raising initial
venture capital who are the folks that
we need to be talking to and how should
we think about initial finances for the
round in the early stages it's not a
stretch of the imagination to say that
we would not be anywhere near as
successful as we are today without what
we learned in entrepreneurship and civil
and environmental engineering my
co-founder and I like to require right
to refer to it as having grown-up
supervision at the very early stages the
company and professors really helped put
us on a path the success from my advice
for potential students in the program is
dream big don't don't go into the
program you know with small aspirations
really the program sets you up to be a
venture-backed company and to be a
venture-backed company and attract
capital you need a large addressable
market that's one of the things you
learn in the class and and so dream big
and you know the sky's the limit don't
let anything work you back